on this final weekend of campaigning joe
biden left his home base of delaware for
stops in must-win pennsylvania
and upper midwest swing states joining
us now from minneapolis senator amy
klobuchar a key supporter of the vice
president
senator a lot of people were surprised
on friday to see
not just president trump but former vice
president biden
in the state of minnesota a state that
hasn't voted for a republican for
president
in 11 straight elections since richard
nixon back in 1972
but there's a reason let's look at the
latest real clear politics average of
recent polls biden
leads the president in minnesota 48
percent to 43.3 percent pretty close
so the question is are minnesota's 10
electoral votes
in play i don't believe they
are and i was so pleased that vice
president biden stopped by
he was in wisconsin he was in iowa he is
a you point out
in pennsylvania today he's all over the
midwest and
seriously chris he is ahead of minnesota
in many other polls by double
digits he's ahead in wisconsin where i
am going today
uh bravely going as a vikings fan to
green bay to meet up with tammy baldwin
uh the senator from wisconsin he is
ahead
in so many states in the midwest why one
he's leading with manufacturing in a big
way and buying america
two he has been willing to take on the
fact
that we are not two separate countries
that we must unite our nation and that
is really important right now
in the midwest struggling big time with
the coronavirus and the last thing i add
suburban voters in the midwest
after your debate that you moderated
where he interrupted you over a hundred
times
he took the stage and said why don't
suburban women like me
well i can tell you as someone that grew
up in the suburbs
they don't like the lack of civility
i asked corey about voter suppression
but i want to take a look at at a case
in minnesota where traditionally that
votes have to be in received by the
election board
before the end of election night to be
counted but the state this year made a
change
and said that if votes are postmarked by
election day they can come in as much as
seven days later and still be counted so
by a two to one vote a federal appeals
court said those votes that don't come
in by election day are going to be
separated and
kept kept separate until a court can
rule whether they should be counted or
not
that's a pretty dramatic change in the
rules isn't that a legitimate challenge
by the republicans
well first of all chris the republicans
and the trump campaign actually agreed
to a consent decree where we would do it
differently
so they could be postmarked by the
election because
of the pandemic then two electors went
around republican electors and went to
the
court we really are focused right now on
making sure people can vote and we're
just telling them
don't vote by mail anymore take your
ballot to a drop-off box we've got
plenty of them in minnesota it's not
like
texas where people are still valiantly
voting that only have one per county
and then i show up in person we have
early voting going on all day today
tomorrow election day so we still feel
really good about the voting in
minnesota we are number one in the
country
nearly every presidential election for
voting so we're
positive about it but it is an example
of the kind of
attempts we're seeing to cut people out
from voting i think it's wrong
i want to talk to you about some issues
in the final presidential
debate joe biden said that he would
these are his words transition
from the oil industry and during the
democratic
primary debates when you were running
against joe biden during one of them he
said he would
eliminate fracking he's kind of tried to
pull back from both of those statements
here's what the president said this week
about joe biden
joe biden confirmed his plan to abolish
the entire
u.s oil industry i said you mean no more
oil gel
well that's what i mean
[Applause]
biden says he wants zero net emissions
of greenhouse gases by 2050
fact is if if you're going to really do
all those things that he's talking about
it's going to hurt a lot of people
who depend on fossil fuels for jobs
well let me clarify the facts first of
all he has
made very clear that he is not against
fracking he just wants to have safety
rules in place
and natural gas
i mean again let me let me just send her
let me fact check okay he has said he
will not
allow any new fracking on federal lands
okay that is that is correct but we're
talking about uh existing fracking
secondly
um what he's talking about is stopping
these oil subsidies and transitioning to
renewable fuel to bring down
greenhouse gas emissions look at the
fires raging and the west coast our
military
predicted this chris that this would
happen and that's what happened this
past fall
you look at all the flooding we're
seeing the weird weather events the
increase in
hurricanes the effect that has had on
the state of florida
they're still coming in and i think that
what he is talking about is shared by
scientists and by
actually our own military that we need
to start tackling this problem and he's
going to do it in a smart way
that will eventually add more jobs to
america i think that's what's important
but i did want to get at some of the
economic arguments that
uh corey was making in this segment
before i went on i thought you're really
fascinating from facts
but no no i got you know i'm what
thank you you're the moderator uh thank
you
thank you i sometimes forget that uh
beyond the presidential race the other
big election news of course
is the race for control of the senate
the the current margin 5347
you need a net pickup of of
four to control the senate or if biden
wins a net pickup of three
because then vice president kamala
harris would be able to break
the type out i want to look because
you're in a cl you have a close race
you're not in it but a close race in
minnesota put it up on the screen
real clear politics rates the minnesota
race between the incumbent democratic
senator
tina smith and republican congressman
jason lewis as a toss-up quickly
what are the chances that smith will win
hold on to that seat and what are the
chances the democrats will take over
control of the senate
um the smith holding onto seat i put at
100 percent poll came out today
she's nine points ahead the senate races
uh we are ahead in arizona we're ahead
in colorado
we are ahead in a number of polls in
maine
we are ahead the polls go back and forth
in iowa north carolina we're ahead
uh we are doing well in states like
georgia south carolina alaska
you name it so i am feeling good about
the senate i can't give you a percentage
on that
but remember i just want to say to your
viewers here if you are sick and tired
of a president
that has not done what he has said he's
done which is not keep americans safe
uh when we have coronavirus spiking pick
a guy that's got a plan
that's listening to the science who's
going to do something about it and get
the vaccine out
in a way that makes sense um this is
really final heart and soul
the argument here at the end yeah
senator
as you said i'm the moderator or in this
case the host
uh senator uh joe biden and you ran
in the centrist lanes during the
primaries but
uh it's been interesting watching what's
happened in the last few days
elizabeth warren is indicating that she
would like to be secretary of the
treasury
uh bernie sanders has talked about
pushing for secretary of labor kamala
harris who would be vice president
is rated the most liberal member of the
senate if joe biden wins
isn't the left going to come after him
really hard after the election
chris right now joe biden is focused on
uniting this country and our party has
stayed united but what i think is really
important to realize
he has brought in people like john
kasich former governor republican
governor of ohio
cindy mccain but he's not going to be
he's not going to be in the cabinet i'm
talking about elizabeth warren as
treasury secretary or bernie sanders i
have no idea who he's going to pick for
the cabinet
what i do know is the way he has run
this campaign
the way he said he's going to be the
president not just for the people that
vote for him but the people that vote
against him that's how he's going to
govern
he has got so much to do in those first
100 days
and i just think that this election if
it goes down the way we're seeing with
him ahead in places like georgia and
some polls in texas
this is going to be the country saying
enough of the divide
enough of the fighting we want to go
together as team
team america and move forward and win
this thing for our country and that
means taking on this virus
shutting down the virus and opening up
our economy
that's what this is about senator club
senator klobuchar thank you
thanks for your time this weekend always
good to talk with you